IS "CONNECT THE WORLD."
>> HELLO, I'M MAX FOSTER.
HELLO AND WELCOME TO "CONNECT
THE WORLD."
BRITISH PRIME MINISTER BORIS
JOHNSON MAY FEEL LIKE HE'S BEING
HAUNTED BY A TRIO OF
RULEBREAKING GATHERINGS
ALLEGEDLY HELD LAST CHRISTMAS
ACROSS THE UK GOVERNMENT DURING
LOCKDOWN.
WE INVESTIGATED AS PRESSURE
GROWS ON THE PRIME MINISTER,
MR. JOHNSON HIMSELF GAVE AN
IMPROMPTU SPEECH AND AN ALLEGED
DECEMBER 18th PARTY IS ALREADY
SENDING SHOCK WAVES OF OUTRAGE
ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
AS THE BACKLASH INTENSIFIES, THE
PRIME MINISTER QUICKLY ROLLED
OUT WHAT HE'S CALLING PLAN B, A
TIGHTENING OF PANDEMIC RULES TO
CURB THE SPREAD OF THE OMICRON
VARIANT.
HE'S ADVISING PEOPLE IN ENGLAND
TO WORK FROM HOME IF POSSIBLE.
HE'S ALSO EXPANDING MASK WEARING
AND MANDATING THE USE OF VACCINE
PASSPORTS IN LARGE VENUES.
>> LET'S DO EVERYTHING WE CAN TO
PROTECT OURSELVES AND OUR LOVED
ONES THIS WINTER AND TO REDUCE
THE PRESSURES.
AS WE LEARN MORE, SO WE WILL BE
GUIDED BY THE HARD MEDICAL DATA
AROUND FOUR KEY CRITERIA.
THE EFFICACY OF OUR VACCINES AND
OUR BOOSTERS, THE SEVERITY OF
OMICRON, THE SPEED OF ITS
SPREAD, AND THE RATE OF
HOSPITALIZATIONS.
>> THE TIMING OF THIS SO-CALLED
PLAN B IS SENSITIVE.
SOME CRITICS IN BORIS JOHNSON'S
OWN CONSERVATIVE PARTY CLAIM
HE'S USING IT AS A WAY TO
DISTRACT AND DEFLECT.
CNN'S NINA DOSE SANTOS IS ON
DOWNING STREET FOR US.
IT MEANS IT'S NOT GOING TO GO
AWAY UNTIL WE'VE GOT THE RESULT.
>> Reporter: WE KNOW THAT THREE
INVESTIGATIONS ARE TAKING PLACE
AS PER TODAY FROM THE CABINET
OFFICE, WHICH IS ESSENTIALLY THE
BEATING HEART OF THE GOVERNMENT
AND THE MAN WHO IS ENLISTED TO
LOOK AFTER THAT.
THESE THREE EVENTS APPEAR TO
HAVE HAPPENED TWO OF THEM HERE
AT DOWNING STREET, THE PRIME
MINISTER'S OWN OFFICIAL
RESIDENCE WHERE OF COURSE ALL OF
HIS OFFICES ARE.
SOME TIME BETWEEN NOVEMBER AND
DECEMBER OF THIS TIME LAST YEAR,
THERE IS ALSO ANOTHER EVENT THEY
ARE LOOKING INTO INSIDE THE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION.
EVEN THOUGH THIS WAS A YEAR AGO,
IT WAS AT A TIME WHEN LONDON AND
THIS PART OF THE COUNTRY WAS
EFFECTIVELY LOCKED DOWN, AND
CHRISTMAS PARTIES WERE BANNED.
THE PRIME MINISTER INSISTS AND
DID SO AGAIN EARLIER TODAY IN
THE HOUSE OF COMMERCE THAT HE
KNOWS OF NO RULEBREAKING THAT
TOOK PLACE.
BUT ONE OF HIS SENIOR AIDES
STILL HAD TO MAKE A TEARFUL
RESIGNATION YESTERDAY EVENING
AFTER SHE WAS CAUGHT SEEMINGLY
IN AN UNGUARDED REMARK WHEN THEY
WERE REHEARSING FOR A MEDIA
BRIEFING MAKING LIGHT OF THESE
RULES AND THIS ALLEGED CHRISTMAS
PARTY THAT MIGHT OR MIGHT NOT
HAVE TAKEN PLACE HERE A YEAR OR
SO AGO.
THIS IS CREATING CONFUSION TO
PEOPLE IN THE UK AS TO WHETHER
OR NOT THEY SHOULD OR SHOULDN'T
HAVE CHRISTMAS PARTIES.
THIS TIGHTENING OF THE
RESTRICTIONS MEANS THAT AS OF
MONDAY NEXT WEEK, PEOPLE WON'T
BE ABLE TO GO TO THE OFFICE, BUT
THEY MIGHT STILL BE ABLE TO HAVE
A LEGITIMATE CHRISTMAS PARTY
WITH THEIR COLLEAGUES WHILST THE
GOVERNMENT IS STILL EXPLAINING
WHETHER OR NOT IT HAD CHRISTMAS
PARTIES HERE THIS TIME LAST
YEAR.
MAX?
>> OPPOSITION MEMBERS OF
PARLIAMENT CALLING FOR HIS
RESIGNATION.
THEY'VE DONE THAT BEFORE.
IT DOESN'T REALLY GO ANYWHERE AS
LONG AS HE HAS SUPPORT OF THOSE
BACK BENCHERS.
HOW IS IT LOOKING FOR HIM?
>> RECENT POLLS INDICATE THAT
HE'S LOSING SOME OF THAT
POPULARITY EVEN AMONG SOME OF
THE PEOPLE WHO VOTED FOR HIM.
AND IF YOU LISTEN TO SOME OF THE
STATEMENTS MADE IN THE HOUSE OF
COMMONS EARLIER TODAY FROM SOME
OF THE BACKBENCH MPs WHO HAVE
BEEN BECOMING INCREASINGLY
DISGRUNTLED.
THEY ARE STARTING TO SPEAK UP ON
BEHALF OF THEIR CONSTITUENTS.
WHAT THEY WANT IS ANSWERS TO
THIS.
THEY WANT THE PRIME MINISTER TO
BE VERY, VERY CLEAR ABOUT WHAT
HAPPENED.
THE OTHER THING THAT THEY ALSO
WANT IS TO KNOW WHETHER OR NOT
HE REALLY DOES HAVE A PLAN FOR
WHETHER OR NOT CHRISTMAS WILL BE
CANCELED THIS TIME THIS YEAR.
BECAUSE, AS WE KNOW, HE'S MOVED
TO THIS PLAN B.
BUT YESTERDAY EVENING I WAS
SPENDING SOME TIME FILMING IN
THE HOSPITALITY SECTOR SOME
CHRISTMAS PARTIES.
AND THERE'S STILL HUGE CONFUSION
HERE ABOUT WHAT IS OR ISN'T
ALLOWED, WHAT MAY OR MAY NOT
COME.
AND, REMEMBER, TODAY IS A DAY
WHEN THE PRIME MINISTER AND HIS
WIFE WELCOMED THEIR SECOND
CHILD, THE BIRTH OF A DAUGHTER.
NONE OF THAT HAS TAKEN THE ISSUE
OF THE FRONT PAGES.
THIS STORY THAT IS NOWHERE BEING
CALLED PARTY GATE IS STARTING TO
AFFECT THE PRIME MINISTER'S
POPULARITY, MAX.
>> WELL, CONGRATULATIONS FOR
THEIR PERSONAL LIVES, AT LEAST.
>>> SOME ENCOURAGING NEWS ON THE
VACCINE FRONT.
TWO ISRAELI STUDIES FIND BOOSTER
DOSES OF PFIZER'S COVID VACCINE
REDUCE INFECTIONS AND DEATHS BY
90% OR MORE.
IT'S ONE OF SEVERAL NEW PIECES
OF EVIDENCE THAT THEY SAY, YES,
BOOSTERS ARE STILL PROTECTIVE
EVEN AGAINST NEW VARIANTS.
HOWEVER, THERE ARE STILL SO MANY
PEOPLE AROUND THE WORLD STILL IN
NEED OF A FIRST SHOT.
NOW, MY NEXT GUEST INSISTS THAT,
QUOTE, WHOLESALE BOOSTING IS NOT
THE SOLUTION RIGHT NOW, AND THAT
IT IS THE PRIMARY CAUSE OF
VACCINATION THAT IS GOING TO
PROTECT AGAINST SEVERE DISEASE
AND DEATH.
THOSE WORDS FROM THE WORLD
HEALTH ORGANIZATION'S CHIEF
SCIENTIST.
SHE JOINS ME NOW FROM GENEVA.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR JOINING
US.
SPEAKING TO YOU FROM LONDON,
THERE ARE RESTRICTIONS HERE
COMING IN.
THEY'RE NOT AS SEVERE AS THEY
ARE IN OTHER PARTS OF EUROPE.
AND THAT'S BECAUSE THE
GOVERNMENT SAYS THAT THE BEST
LINE OF DEFENSE FOR BRITS HERE
IS THE BOOSTER PROGRAM.
WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF THAT?
>> THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THAT
QUESTION.
AT THE W.H.O., OF COURSE, WE
HAVE TO TAKE A GLOBAL VIEW AND
THEN COUNTRIES PUT IN PLACE THE
POLICIES AND IMPLEMENT THEM
DEPENDING ON THEIR LOCAL
CONTEXT.
WHEN WE TAKE A GLOBAL VIEW, IT'S
CLEAR THAT WE STILL HAVE ABOUT
HALF THE WORLD THAT HAS NOT
RECEIVED THE PRIMARY COURSE OF
VACCINATION, INCLUDING THE FACT
THAT ONLY ONE IN FOUR HEALTHCARE
WORKERS IN AFRICA HAVE BEEN
FULLY VACCINATED.
AND THERE ARE PLENTY OF
VULNERABLE PEOPLE OUT THERE THAT
STILL NEED TO GET THEIR FIRST
AND THEIR SECOND SHOTS.
NOW, DATA FROM COUNTRY AFTER
COUNTRY, INCLUDING THE U.S., THE
UK, ISRAEL, CHILE, ET CETERA,
SHOW THAT THE PEOPLE WHO ARE IN
HOSPITAL NOW AND ESPECIALLY IN
CRITICAL CARE AND THOSE WHO ARE
DYING ARE OVERWHELMINGLY THE
UNVACCINATED.
AND WHILE THERE IS SOME EVIDENCE
WANING OF IMMUNITY, PARTICULARLY
AFTER SIX MONTHS OR SO WITH MANY
OF THE VACCINES AND PARTICULARLY
IN THE OLDER AGE GROUPS, WHAT IS
CLEAR IS THAT ALL OF THE
VACCINES CONTINUE TO OFFER HIGH
DEGREE OF PROTECTION AGAINST
SEVERE DISEASE AND DEATH EVEN AT
SIX MONTHS OUT.
AND SO, YOU KNOW, THE VIEW THAT
WE ARE TAKING IS FOR THIS STAGE
OF THE PANDEMIC, OUR GOAL IS TO
PREVENT DEATHS AS QUICKLY AS
POSSIBLE.
WE ARE STILL SEEING 50,000
DEATHS A WEEK.
THIS IS NOT ACCEPTABLE.
AND, AS I SAID, 97% OR SO OF
THOSE DEATHS ARE IN THE
UNVACCINATED.
IN COUNTRIES ACROSS THE WORLD,
NOT JUST IN THE LOW-INCOME
COUNTRIES.
THAT'S WHY COUNTRIES NEED TO
FOCUS ON GETTING THOSE
UNVACCINATED PEOPLE TO COME IN
AND GET THEIR SHOTS.
BOOSTERS MAYBE FOR SOME
SELECTED, HIGH-RISK GROUPS,
IMMUNOCOMPROMISED AND THE VERY
ELDERLY.
WE ARE NOT RECOMMENDING
LOCKDOWNS.
BUT CERTAINLY UNIVERSAL MASKING,
PAYING ATTENTION TO VENTILATION,
MAKING SURE THAT WE ARE NOT
GATHERING IN BIG GROUPS IN
INDOOR SETTINGS, ALL OF THE
THINGS WE KNOW DRIVE
TRANSMISSION UP.
I THINK THAT'S REALLY GOING TO
HAVE TO BE THE FOCUS FOR THE
COMING WEEKS AND MONTHS.
>> NEW VARIANTS LIKE OMICRON ARE
LESS LIKELY, AREN'T THEY, IN
FUTURE IF COUNTRIES THAT AREN'T
VACCINATED GET THE VACCINE
BECAUSE THESE NEW VARIANTS ARE
MORE LIKELY TO EMERGE OUT OF
COMMUNITIES WHERE THERE'S NO
VACCINATION.
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
THIS WAS ENTIRELY PREDICTABLE.
WE DIDN'T KNOW WHERE AND WHEN
AND WHAT TYPE OF VARIANT WOULD
EMERGE.
BUT AS LONG AS YOU HAVE SURGING
INFECTIONS, ONGOING TRANSMISSION
IN SOME PARTS OF THE WORLD,
NOBODY IS GOING TO BE SAFE
BECAUSE THE VIRUS IS JUST
LOOKING FOR OPPORTUNITIES TO
MUTATE, TO EVOLVE, AND TO BECOME
MORE TRANSMISSIBLE, BASICALLY
THE VIRUS IS CONSTANTLY TRYING
TO MAKE ITSELF MORE EFFICIENT.
AND THAT'S WHAT IT'S DONE NOW.
IT'S MADE ITSELF EVEN MORE
EFFICIENT AT TRANSMITTING.
AND THIS IS LIKELY TO CONTINUE
TO HAPPEN.
THIS IS NOT GOING TO BE THE LAST
VARIANT WE SEE.
AND THAT'S WHY, AGAIN, TO COME
BACK TO THE QUESTION OF WHAT
SHOULD WE DO WITH THE VACCINE
SUPPLIES WE HAVE, THE PRIORITY
SHOULD BE TO VACCINATE THE
HIGH-RISK VULNERABLE GROUPS
ACROSS THE WORLD IN ALL
COUNTRIES BEFORE WE START GIVING
THIRD AND FOURTH SHOTS TO PEOPLE
WHO'VE ALREADY HAD THEIR PRIMARY
COURSE.
>> IT MUST BE VERY FRUSTRATING,
THEN, FOR YOU TO SEE BOOSTER
PROGRAMS BEING RAMPED UP BECAUSE
OF A NEW VARIANT, WHICH COULD
HAVE BEEN LESS LIKELY TO OCCUR
IF VACCINES HAD BEEN GIVEN TO
THE DEVELOPING WORLD AND PARTS
OF AFRICA, FOR EXAMPLE.
I SPOKE IN THE LAST HOUR TO THE
DOCTOR WHO FIRST NOTICED THE
SYMPTOMS OF OMICRON IN SOUTH
AFRICA.
HER VIEW IS THAT THE SYMPTOMS
AREN'T AS BAD AS PEOPLE IN THE
WEST PERHAPS THINK THEY ARE.
AND ACTUALLY THE WEST IS
OVERREACTING TO OMICRON.
IS THAT YOUR VIEW AS WELL?
>> WELL, THE EARLY SIGNS AND
DESCRIPTIONS OF CASES FROM SOUTH
AFRICA IN PARTICULAR BUT ALSO
FROM OTHER COUNTRIES DOES SHOW
THAT MOST OF THE CASES SO FAR
HAVE BEEN MILD, WE HAVEN'T HAD
DEATHS REPORTED.
BUT THAT'S USUALLY THE CASE AT
THE BEGINNING OF EVERY NEW WAVE
WITH A NEW VARIANT.
SO WE NEED TO BE A LITTLE MORE
CAUTIOUS BEFORE WE CONCLUDE THAT
THIS IS A MILDER FORM OF THE
VIRUS.
AND EVEN IF IT IS, WHICH WE HOPE
IT IS, THE FACT THAT YOU'RE
GOING TO HAVE VERY LARGE NUMBERS
BECAUSE IT'S SO HIGHLY
TRANSMISSIBLE WILL STILL MEAN
THAT PEOPLE ARE GOING TO GET
SICK.
SO I THINK WE STILL NEED TO GO
BACK TO THE BASICS.
AND THE DIFFERENCE TODAY IS THAT
WE ARE IN A DIFFERENT POSITION.
WE HAVE A LOT OF TOOLS AT OUR
DISPOSAL.
WE HAVE DIAGNOSTICS, WE HAVE
VACCINES, WE HAVE THERAPEUTICS.
WE NEED TO USE THEM WISELY AND
EQUITABLY.
SO, YES, WE WERE NOT SURPRISED.
AND I HOPE WE'VE HAD MANY, MANY
WAKE-UP CALLS AND REMINDERS.
THIS IS THE FIFTH VARIANT THAT
WE'VE SEEN.
I DO HOPE AT LEAST NOW THAT
COUNTRIES WILL WAKE UP TO THE
REALITY THAT